hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
at the very core of John chrysostom's
homily 16 on the gospel of Matthew is
this discussion of anger and
specifically the three precepts that
Christ is giving one right after the
other and trying to explain what's
actually going on in these now these are
supposed to be sort of an amplification
of the law a way of adding to it of
explaining it of you could say even
consolidating it and the three precepts
run like this he who is angry with his
brother without cause will be subject to
the Judgment we'll talk about that
without cause in just a moment the
second one whoever says raqqa to his
brother shall be in danger of the
council and then the third one whosoever
shall say thou fool shall be in danger
of Hellfire and there's no actual
explanation of these given in The Sermon
on the Mount and these have been
troubling you could say or provoking the
thought of Christians really sense the
gospels were you know circulated around
and chrysostom is explaining it himself
now the first one I mentioned that we'd
come back to this without cause
so there are different variations on the
manuscripts and some of the manuscripts
of The Sermon on the Mount
contain the word AKA and some of them
did not contain that and then there's a
lot of discussion among Christian
authors whether we should pay attention
to this or not so for example John
Cassian says I don't care if there's an
AKA without cause in there don't get
angry Augustine on the contrary and John
chrysostom will say well no this this
kind of matters you know some of the
texts do say without cause let's think
about what that could mean so let's look
at what he has to say about the first of
these precepts or commands he who is
angry with his brother without cause
will be subject to the Judgment so what
does that actually mean so chrysostom is
going to say
um
he is not all together taken the thing
anger away first because it's not
possible being a human being not to get
angry at all to be freed of all the
passions he says we can get you know
control over them but to be all together
without them is out of the question
that's just I mean maybe there's
somebody down the line who's like that
but that's not us right so we need to
think about well when are we angry with
and without cause and this leads us to
thinking about well what is anger for
what is the purpose of it so he says
this passion is useful if we know how to
use it at the right or appropriate time
and he says look at you know Paul being
angry at the Corinthians and how it
delivered them from a grievous pest so
by the same means again he recovered the
people of the Galatians who'd Fallen
aside so then you know when is the
proper time for anger when should we get
angry and here Chris system is gonna
transform it a little bit he's actually
not going to talk about time so much as
reason or motivation what is the purpose
of the anger that we feel so he says
when we're not avenging ourselves or
getting retribution for ourselves but
checking others in their Lawless
transgressions or forcing them to attend
in their negligence so when people are
doing the wrong thing and not not
worrying about whether it's affecting us
or not whether it's affecting others
whether it's affecting those very people
who are doing wrong so anger could be
suitable for restraining other people
for calling their attention to what
they're not paying attention to for
um protecting others
and so he says well what is the
unsuitable time when we're avenging
ourselves so we shouldn't be doing that
or when we're contending for riches as
well right and he says
um you know a lot of us don't pay
attention to that we do the contrary we
become like wild beasts when they're
injured but remiss and cowardly when we
see things being done to other people
and then it's very interesting what he
says here
both of which are opposite to the laws
of the Gospel so it could be
good for us to be angry within certain
limits when we are protecting others
when we're addressing injustices when
we're doing the right thing with it you
could say
so much for that one what about the
second one this is a little bit
mysterious because what the hell is
raqqa Right whoever says raqqa to his
brother shall be in danger of the
council and it can be like well I don't
I don't say raqqa very often so
um I'm not going to have any problems
with that right I don't even say it with
homonyms like rock and roll you know or
something like that uh well what is
raqqa it's it's a word uh and he says
this is a word of of the syrians so this
is Aramaic right and Jesus is using a
term that would be familiar to his
audience and he's saying don't say this
to somebody else it's sort of like when
Southerners have that expression oh
bless your heart right it's sort of like
saying oh you know you you silly person
um and so he tells us that it's not an
expression of great insolence or insult
right it's kind of a small thing
but
it does Express
some contempt some looking down on the
other person and sliding making less of
them so it's not a good thing to do he
says we giving orders either to our
servants or to an inferior person say
away with you you hear tell such a one
and and so you know he tells us that God
doesn't want human beings to be doing
this certainly motivated by anger he
says God the lover of human beings Roots
up even the least false commanding us to
behave to one another in a seemly manner
and with due respect and this with a
view of destroying thereby also the
greater so this this is
letting anger lead us to showing
disrespect to other people which very
often happens right when we get angry
then we have another thing whoever shall
say thou fool shall be in danger of
Hellfire
and about this
um chrysostom actually tells us the most
he says to a lot of people this appears
too harsh right
um why should we go to hell or be in
danger of the Hellfire for saying this
person's a fool especially if they are a
fool right for just calling as we say a
spade a spade and so a lot of people
think that this is hyperbolic what is
hyperbolic mean sort of like over the
top you know you're not really going to
be threatened with Hellfire it's just a
figure of speech God doesn't really mean
it Jesus doesn't really mean it when
he's saying this in The Sermon on the
Mount it's just to like scare us so
we're not saying fool fool fool the
people all the time and
criticism says you know I'm kind of
worried uh last when we have deceived
ourselves with words here we may indeed
there suffer that extreme punishment we
should not try to pretend this is
hyperbolic and then he says why do
people think that this commandment is
overburdened some you know why why is it
too much and then he says listen here's
some considerations that you should take
into mind he says words are the
beginnings for many sins and really
they're the medium of many sinful
comportments as well so he gives
examples of this
says by words are blasphemies so
blasphemies is when you say something
against you know God or the Divine or
you're being kind of fast and loose with
that denials are by words revilings and
reproaches so when you're like
complaining about somebody and you're
saying oh they're terrible right that is
uh done with words uh perjuries bearing
false witness you're not supposed to lie
right bearing false witness doesn't just
mean in a court of law uh you're so
you're not supposed to be lying about
other things and so he says well so this
is don't look at this as a mere word but
whether it has you know danger this is
what you need to think about and then he
says are you ignorant that in the season
of enmity or hatred when wrath is
inflamed and the Soul kindled even the
least thing appears great and what is
not very reproachable is counted
intolerable often these little things
have given birth even to murder and
overthrown whole cities just as where
friendship is even Grievous things are
light so we're enmity Lies Beneath very
Trifles appear intolerable so when
people are ready to get angry calling
them a fool can really bring that anger
out and you know whether you're doing it
motivated by your own anger or just to
mess with them you know as we say to own
somebody it's it's bad and it's uh you
know you're liable to the ultimate
punishment in that case he he goes on
and he says
um
however simply a word be spoken it is
surmised to have been spoken with an
evil meaning I mean if you with most
people if you call them a fool you're
saying something that's meant to hurt
right it's meant to push buttons it's
meant to get them riled up and he gives
you all sorts of you know interesting
metaphors here basically I'll just give
you one of them uh with fire if there's
just a small spark though thousands of
planks Lie by it doesn't easily lay hold
of them but if the flame is waxed strong
and high it readily seizes not planks
only but stones and all materials that
fall in its way right and so um you know
you shouldn't be calling somebody fool
and he says therefore for him who calls
fool Christ has added the fire of hell
now for the first time mentioning the
name of Hell in in the account right so
you know we've got three different
things here
chrysostom goes on and he says look at
how the these are arranged with each
other you know they're coming one right
after the other this is actually sort of
like a gradual process of saying hey
don't do this
oh you did that well don't do this at
least oh you went that far don't do this
he talks about
Christ proceeding by little and little
in his punishments all but excusing
himself onto you and signifying that his
desire indeed is to threaten nothing of
the kind but we human beings because
we're screw-ups we go on and we lead
them to the point where he has to
threaten us with with Hellfire right so
he says
for observe I told you don't be angry
for nothing because you're in danger of
the Judgment okay well you did that uh
you've despised the former commandment
see what anger has produced it's LED you
straightway to insult you've called your
brother raqqa and so that's not good
again I said another punishment the
council and then you overlook even that
and proceed to what is even more
Grievous I will visit thee no longer
with these finite punishments but with
the undying penalty of Hell lest after
this you would Break Forth even to
murder and he goes on Chris's stub and
he says there's nothing in the world
more intolerable than insolence it has
what very great power to sting a
person's soul but the when the word to
which is spoken in itself more wounding
than the insolence The Blaze becomes
twice as great then he says you know you
might look at the word fool is not a big
deal but what are you actually saying
when you call somebody a fool
you're saying that they're not really
human because you know what is what is
really essential to us as human beings
is our intelligence he says mind and the
understanding when of this you've robbed
your brother you've deprived your
brother of all
goodness nobility you know what it is
that makes us uh human and he says so
you know let's think about the the words
themselves consider how great a wound is
made by this word and on to how much
evil it proceeds what is it that
um
these these threats or these
Commandments are supposed to do well
chrysostom tells us that it's to remove
the roots and the sources of hatred and
why that because what the gospel is
about is love we're supposed to love
each other and you know love people who
love each other will get angry with each
other but
we want to try to avoid that as much as
possible and then when we are angry
let's not make the other person suffer
by calling them all sorts of bad things
let alone going on to actually injure
them so he goes on and he says
um Christ makes much account of love
this being Above All Things the mother
of every good and the badge of his
disciples and the bond which holds
together our whole condition so with
reason he's removing with great
earnestness the roots and sources of
that hatred and he goes on and he says
don't think that these sayings are
hyperbolical consider the good done by
them and admire thee it is interesting
the mildness of these laws the mildness
means the opposite of anger these laws
are not being given in Anger these laws
are being given precisely to curb anger
Among Us human beings who are you know
liable to give into and feel that that
passion so that we don't do
stupid things and hateful things as a
result of that anger and make things
worse so he says there's nothing which
God takes so much pains as this that we
should be United and knit together with
one another so therefore in his own
person and by his disciples as well as
those in the Old and New Testament he
makes so much account to this
commandment and as a severe Avenger and
Punisher of those who despise the duty
in truth nothing so effectually gives
entrance and route to wickedness as the
taking away of love so love is supposed
to be there
these modes of anger these things that
we do out of anger get in the way of
that and uh substitute hatred or at
least the passion of anger in place of
love and so that's why there is this
sort of escalation
of rules of precepts of advice given by
according to chrysostom God himself in
in the figure of Christ to us human
beings in the teachings uh in The Sermon
on the Mount